vous regrettez aujourd'hui ou pas après
tout ce qui s'est passé malheureusement
quels sont les moyens que j'ai
aujourd'hui pour regretter le geste
alors que des infirmières ont été
licenciées et que par dessus ça Emmanuel
Macron dit vouloir les emmerder alors
certains ont dit que vous aviez gifiés
président par revendication parce que
vous étiez gilet jaune royaliste je suis
gilet jaune oui d'accord oui mais tous
les gilets jaunes ne gifle pas le
président
non je ne pense pas mais qui c'est qui
peut déjà l'approcher non mais Juan
brocante vous en tant que en tant
qu'avocat est-ce que vous comprenez le
geste de
ne pas comprendre le geste ce que je
vois c'est que cet homme a fait de la
détention alors qu'il avait pas de
casier dans une situation où lorsque
vous voyez l'impunité qui règne dans ce
pays il y a un tweet de Julien Courbet
d'ailleurs je sais pas si vous l'avez vu
sur cette affaire qui a fait beaucoup de
bruit vous le raconte que son père a été
écrasé par un chauffard ivre trois mois
avec sursis et voyez là vous ayez fait
tout un laïus sur l'affaire Lola et sur
le fait qu'il fallait une justice rapide
on sait que c'est un des drames de ce
pays la capacité à traiter justement des
drames rapidement en tout cas avec
suffisamment de célérité là pour le coup
c'est pas des problèmes qui se posent
lorsque ça touche les puissants de notre
pays c'est pareil elle avait été
condamné en même pas 48 heures série de
même pas eu le temps d'organiser sa
défense tout de suite envoyé aux trous
comme on dit pas défendu en première
instance donc j'étais très heureux de
d'avoir cette audience en appel pour
qu'il est au moins l'opportunité de
[Musique]
c'était dur ça vous
ça s'est plutôt bien passé même si on
était difficile vous étiez incarcéré où
à Valence d'accord vous étiez seul dans
la cellule ou vous étiez oui j'ai été
mis à l'isolement
qu'est-ce qui vous disait
ils n'ont pas du tout été hostile vous
savez pourquoi vous étiez là oui il le
savait il l'avait vu aux informations
d'accord il vous disait quoi bah il
n'avait aucune hostilité à mon égard
malgré le fait que j'étais catalogué de
droite par la télévision ils avaient
aucune aucune hostilité d'accord alors
aujourd'hui donc quatre mois de prison
vous avez fait 4 mois de prison et vous
avez interdiction d'exercer une fonction
ou un emploi public de manière
définitive et la privation de vos droits
civiques comme le droit de vote civile
de famille pour une durée de trois ans
et de porter une arme soumise à
autorisation donc on n'est pas loin
est-ce que vous trouvez la peine au
clémente vous vous dites non vraiment la
peine est bien la peine est bien elle
est pas elle est pas trop clémente
c'était bien qu'il aille en prison je
déteste dire cette phrase mais les
institutions faut pas y toucher faut pas
toucher aux pompiers faut pas toucher
aux policiers faut pas toucher aux
infirmières
après faut pas toucher aux gens qui qui
sont là qui représentent quelque chose
si à chaque déplacement notre président
de la République parce que c'est le
nôtre c'est notre Président c'est le
président de la France qu'on aime ou
qu'on n'aime pas monsieur Macron c'est
notre Président il se fait gifler à
chaque fois qu'il sort vous rendez
compte l'image qu'on renvoie dans le
monde serait drôle opposition
la France c'est quoi toi ça te fait
marrer
mais voilà moi ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que tu es fait quatre mois la
prison c'est très dur 4 mois c'est
beaucoup 4 mois de prison c'est beaucoup
ça arrive ça ça réfléchir j'espère que
tu auras plus envie de gifler des gens
Matthieu moi c'est bien moi pardon je
suis beaucoup plus sévère d'abord ça
fait rire l'avocat je comprends pas
depuis tout à l'heure il rigole et
depuis tout à l'heure il dit même pas il
regrette le président de la cour d'appel
riait aussi pendant le trimestre
mais bien sûr parce qu'en fait vous
rendez pas compte à quel point ce geste
a une valeur purgatoire pour des
Français certes des Français qui sont
maîtrisés au quotidien vous n'êtes pas
les autres arrêtez de faire passer les
personnes vous n'êtes pas d'accord
les gens qui savent pas quoi dire moi
les Français me disent pas les prendre
disent attention tout ce que je vois
c'est que c'est un monsieur aujourd'hui
vous allez s'énerver parce qu'on a déjà
reçu une fois il avait présenté aucun
regret vous non plus vous risquons vous
fait rire c'est mieux vous êtes bien
Guignols ça vous fait rire c'est pas
drôle ce qui s'est passé
dans la République il a frappé une
fonction il a humilié un pays je suis
désolé
comment quand il a vu des humoristes à
réaliser
dans la rue pour quelqu'un d'autre je
peux marcher tranquillement les gens
viennent parce que vous me remercier
comment ça se fait que les gens viennent
pour me remercier ces trois dans la rue
non non non non non non c'est des gens
que je ne connais pas tu me reconnaisse
pour lui donc vous les connaissez pas
les gens vous pensez que
on se calme 2 minutes
c'est intéressant est-ce que s'il y
avait eu un juré populaire est-ce que
des citoyens français s'ils avaient été
réunis
on peut ne pas être d'accord avec
Emmanuel Macron ne le gifle pas mais
voilà exactement voilà c'est des
opposants politiques il y a un autre
élément important
village français qui justement
contrairement à Mélenchon contrairement
à vous qui avez un accès à l'espace
public ne se fait pas entendre et ça
c'est un problème de millions de
Français
il voit monsieur Macron arrivé dans son
village et pour une fois faire mine de
s'intéresser à lui en bras de chemise
comme ça dynamique vas-y donne-moi la
main etc et il a une réaction de rejet
il y a une réaction de rejet qui
consiste pas une allégation caractérisée
consiste pas à lui faire du mal
symboliquement il lui met ce qu'il a
appelé un soufflet symboliquement en
fait à égalité
c'est pour savoir
quels sont les moyens d'action qui sont
disponible on a vu les gilets jaunes
quand ils ont fait bornier quand ils
sont fait gazer quand ils essayent de se
faire entendre c'est ça les moyens
d'action qui aujourd'hui dans ce pays
entendre vous reprenez
quelqu'un
qui manifestants
on a braqué une arme à feu sur moi c'est
pas de la violence
à feu sur moi
une arme à feu est-ce que ça c'est pas
de la violence je connais pas la
situation
et ça va être compliqué pour lui dresser
dans ce pays et ça c'est une question
qui devrait nous interroger je suis pas
en train de valider
le président de la République de la
politique évident de la République se
retrouve dans une situation d'être
confronté à ce genre de de geste et
comment ça se fait qu'il va demain
aujourd'hui dans son propre pays avoir
du mal à pouvoir sortir dans la rue
si je peux me permettre
je vais vous dire Emmanuel et Nicolas
Sarkozy c'était c'était compliqué
c'était compliqué pour lui aussi avant
chaque soir
Jacques Chirac c'était compliqué il y en
a pour qui c'était pas compliqué parce
qu'il dit rien c'était François Hollande
non mais c'est vrai voilà François
Hollande on savait on savait même plus
qu'il était président ça vous intéresse
pas que dans un pays dans ce pays en
fait on arrive à un niveau de violence
vis-à-vis des institutions et des hommes
politiques qui sont ces représenter tout
le pays mais qui fait ce qu'il y a des
gens qui viennent féliciter Monsieur
tarel dans la rue c'est pour son geste
avec des gens en tout cas
sur 15 minutes
pardon je vais vous défendre un peu donc
laissez-moi vos voilà
Mathieu il y a quand même jamais eu
autant de personnes soit dans la rue
soit dans la merde soit violente soit
victime de violence donc ça c'est quand
même un fait ensuite attends attends
que ce soit en fariné c'est un symbole
alors oui chez des barres ou quoi c'est
un grand pas
mal
sur le président
maintenant la question pardon game je
peux finir pardon par contre la question
de dire est-ce que ça a été enfin est-ce
que votre sanction est trop légère moi
les gens qui disent ça c'est incroyable
parce que si vous avez des mois de
prison en plus vous serez limite autant
autant inculpé que quelqu'un qui a violé
ou tué des gens parce qu'aujourd'hui
mais si vous avez été très la honte de
la France Monsieur
respectables et donc des institutions
respectées aujourd'hui à chaque fois
tous les soirs sur le plateau on dit que
ce n'est plus respectable parce que ça
parce que ça marche sur la tête non mais
au bout d'un moment reprenons les choses
à la base vous voyez l'évolution de
votre de votre émission par exemple il y
a quelques années c'était principalement
du divertissement et de plus en plus
vous en êtes à traiter des faits divers
des fêtes société pourquoi parce que la
société bien sûr et en fait de dans un
état qui qui vous amène vous-même à
devoir vous saisir de ces questions
parce que vous êtes inquiet de ce qui
est en train de se passer donc il faut
un moment donné commencer à interroger
ces éléments interroger le geste de
Monsieur Tarek comme phénomène social
plutôt que d'être dans une posture
morale qui consiste à dire
est-ce que je condamne c'est tellement
facile moi je vais vous dire je au
contraire moi je suis et je vous le
savez on sait on s'est déjà parlé tous
les deux maintenant ça se passe très
bien même entre nous et c'est vrai que
voilà moi je suis pour le dialogue si on
n'est pas d'accord sur plein de choses
elle croise beaucoup avec Damien moi ce
que je comprends pas c'est qu'il y avait
d'autres moyens si vous lui avez dit je
pense que vous l'auriez encore plus
blessé maman lui disant les choses
devant lui plutôt que de le gifler le
gifler ça vous rendez pas compte c'est
c'est dramatique et puis ça envoie un
message dans la tête des gens dans la
tête de tous les gens qui voient le
président se faire gifler vous rendez
compte ou pas c'est dramatique le geste
il faut que c'est quand même gifler le
Président c'est c'est fou moi pour moi
je je sais pas
mais pour tout le monde ça a été
quelqu'un d'autre mais non non bien sûr
parler les autres vous n'êtes tout le
monde on arrête dans la rue me dit
j'aurais voulu le faire à ta place
j'aurais dû vouloir faire attention à ta
place
parce que je marche dans la rue parce
que je vis dans un petit village oui
qui sont qui comprennent que vous soyez
énervés
un instant juste que les gens disent
c'est est-ce que c'est pas
contre-productif de d'avoir ce geste là
qui fait que on a retenu que ça en fait
quels sont les moyens pour le peuple
aujourd'hui de s'exprimer
vous êtes tous dans votre bulle essayez
de vous mettre à sa place quel est le
moyen d'un villageois
ils font pour se faire entendre face à
la destruction des services publics la
situation sociale à la question
confrontée dans ce pays aujourd'hui
donnez-moi une réponse
Cahuzac ont mis des gifles ils ont
jamais été poursuivi comme des citoyens
des hommes quand c'est un homme
politique c'est vrai que c'est pas grave
une petite claque une petite claque
bien sûr
j'adore les leçons de pardon mais vous
avez pas vu si la grande carrière
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
3 minutes pour venir et puis après
normalement
ça vous dit quelque chose
mais si un point sur lequel on peut pas
l'attaquer c'est celui-là et je sais pas
ce qui vous êtes pour le faire
d'ailleurs parce que c'est des
destinations de voyage
non mais c'est dur quoi
c'est dur de jouer à ce jeu
vous pouvez essayer mais c'est compliqué
ouais ok là l'argumentaire il est pas
très très fort j'aimerais poser une
question à Damien tarel autour de la
gifle Emmanuel Macron est-ce que ça fait
avancer les choses parce que voilà c'est
ça la vraie question mais qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire pour avancer les choses
moi j'aimerais bien savoir
24 mois de tôles on en parle non au
moins je suis intégré avec moi-même j'ai
passé la main ce que j'estime être un
traître à notre pays
quand vous auriez quoi si vous avez pas
mis la gif vous auriez été mettre un
traître à notre pays non Emmanuel Macron
est un très très d'accord objectivement
avec la fermeture c'est la vente
d'Alstom tout ça c'est de la haute
trahison pourquoi vous l'avez pas dans
un autre temps dans une autre époque
voilà je suis pas une gifle
dans un autre temps
non non non 2 minutes lui là mais non
mais il parle d'une autre époque il
aurait été pendu dans une autre époque
en paraît fouettée
[Applaudissements]
du quotidien la violence nous on est
contre la violence tous les soirs tous
les soirs ici on dénonce la violence
vous avez pas vu le constatez cette
phrase de l'abbé Pierre sur le fait que
c'est facile pour un bourgeois d'être
contre la violence
les premiers mois qu'il y a eu j'étais
sur les ronds à discuter avec eux j'ai
vu leur profil aujourd'hui j'ai été à
fond dedans jamais et alors que je fasse
payer pour pour
rembourser mes crédits et jamais de
commentaires de de trucs politiques
sors-moi une émission sortez-moi
monsieur l'avocat une émission où j'ai
fait un commentaire anti Front national
anti-tout j'ai fait anti tout le monde
moi je suis pas Macron j'ai fait anti
tout le monde j'ai pas de trucs
c'est de vous rappeler que justement
[Applaudissements]
je vais vraiment venir tu as un pour moi
tu es un bonhomme donc me demande pas de
venir te mettre une boxe pour de vrai
mais non c'est des conneries qui
racontent c'est pas comme ça qu'on fait
oui mais c'est pas comme ça complètement
dans les 15 derniers mois des gens mais
il arrive là que c'est col roulé j'ai
fait les présidents il était fou toi
arrête c'est pas comme ça mais oui mais
c'est pas comme ça qu'on fait regarde
comment on fait dans une dans cette
société aujourd'hui quand on fait partie
du peuple vous voyez pas quand on a
accès aux personnes
en démocratie
il va manifester il se fait gazer je
suis d'accord avec toi il y a la police
qui a eu des débordements je vais
t'expliquer comment on fait je vais
t'expliquer comment faire moi j'aimerais
bien savoir
prenez votre cerveau prends un cerveau
pour deux écoutez bien comment on fait
écoute il y a deux tours dans une
élection le premier tour on vote le
deuxième tour on vote quand il y a un
résultat on ferme sa gueule ou on se
casse
on peut pas faire autrement que ça
s'appelle la démocratie qu'est-ce que tu
veux faire
n'importe qui aurait gagné face à Marine
Le Pen n'importe qui gagne face à
extrême droite un légume organisation
c'est ce qui arrive aux États-Unis
politiquement parlant parce qu'il y a
une élection moi vous trouvez que ça
marche bien moi j'ai pas le choix
l'élection elle est comme ça il y a il y
a eu un résultat c'est comme ça
je vais essayer de vous faire entendre
démocratie
j'ai vu que ça a pas marché
ils ont rien ils ont eu des choses c'est
passé je suis d'accord mais ils ont eu
des choses après le faites votre
démarche de dire on va gifler le
président qui dit qu'il fait c'est ce
qu'il dit je vérifie le Président c'est
présenté c'est ce que tu as fait tu as
fait du bien on va être honnête tu as
fait du bien à beaucoup de gens oui
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de gens quand
ils agissent la macro ils ont dit voilà
il a pris une gif c'est bien fait parce
qu'il a fait quelque chose que nous on
aurait voulu faire maintenant c'est pas
bien ne crois pas que c'est bien dans ta
personne ne dis pas dans la rue aux gens
qui te disent oui c'est bien ne va pas
leur dire merci tiens je fais une photo
moi je pense que vous avez dit c'est
plus important vous avez dit en effet ça
fait du bien des Français il faut qu'on
s'interroge sur pourquoi ce geste et ça
fait du mal c'est tout ça fait du mal à
la France
combien de personnes dans ta vie
excuse-moi de parler beaucoup je ne suis
pas quelqu'un de violent Emmanuel Macron
parce que tu savais qui t'arriverai rien
non je fais d'autres non
je te propose énormément
de quartier après la dernière émission
chez vous j'étais à génération hip-hop
sous le radio j'étais avec les gars donc
d'accord
j'adore l'accusation le renversé le
renversement de la cuisine quelques
personnes qui m'ont insulté tu es
quelqu'un de violent tu fais juste
toi-même bien sûr c'est quand Damien
attendez on va pas rentrer dans ces
histoires c'est n'importe quoi
[Musique]
le pouvoir sur les Français
Macron ça dit [ __ ] j'ai pris une balle
il faut que je change tout le temps
ça
c'est moi-même c'est moi qui suis court
comme une savate je suis bien parce que
vous écoute
on sait que ça ne mène pas à se poser
des questions mais rien à [ __ ]
qui a été faire le concrètement en
prison à manger des sardines c'est lui
c'est pas Emmanuel Macron
non pas du tout c'est plutôt bien nourri
d'ailleurs
placard pour ta petite gif de merde là
tu es resté au placard 4 mois comme un
crétin il faisait leur vie ils allaient
au restaurant il s'en fout de ta gueule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est-ce que toi tu es pour le retour d'un
roi
hein
hors de propos mais moi
dans une démocratie en profondeur et la
mesure pour moi qui indispensable c'est
le retour fait un dôme au RIC
c'est-à-dire que le peuple doit pouvoir
voter pour autre chose que des
représentants on en a marre d'être
présenté par par des institutions des
castes parisiennes éloignés de la voter
comme toi mais voyez combien de fois on
a entendu ce propos
au final on a passé pardon il a pas voté
est-ce qu'on peut être gentil avec nos
invités
[Rires]
d'exprimer son mécontentement c'est
d'aller dans les dans les rues il y a eu
des millions de gilets jaunes qui ont
bloqué ça n'a rien changé vous dites le
but c'est de voter mais ce qui s'est
passé là cette élection c'est pas tout
le monde qui a voté pour Macron c'est
tout le monde qui a voté contre Marine
Le Pen donc je suis désolé
arrête de lui dire arrête de dire on a
tous voté pour Macron parce que ce qui
s'est passé sur cette élection c'est
c'est pas comme les autres élections
on va pas rentrer dans de la police
qui m'intéresse c'est la réponse de de
mon voisin un peu énervé qui consiste en
réponse à à dire peu importe mais peu
importe non enfin peu importe pour lui
probablement parce qu'il a un niveau de
vie qui lui permet de se dire on s'en
fiche mais il y a des millions de
Français qui sont dans cette situation
moi je sais assez bien pour que sur
votre situation personnelle oui je suis
assez au scénariste
vous n'êtes pas vous n'êtes pas dans une
situation de souffrance comme leçon de
millions de Français aujourd'hui c'est
donc évidemment que peu importe que tous
les jours évidemment que
pour vous évidemment peu importe pour
vous évidemment que si vous retrouvez
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
non peut-être pas l'événementiel c'est
assez large de t'avoir Emmanuel Macron
j'aurais aimé qu'on puisse communiquer
non mais voilà bah oui
et nous déjà tout a été dit et on n'a
pas été entendu nous les gilets jaunes
le peuple
de gifler un autre membre du
gouvernement je n'ai jamais prévu de
gifler qui que ce soit mais si j'arrive
vers vous et je vous insulte je pense
que quand même vous allez mettre une
gifle c'est comment je vous insulte
j'estime que vous allez mettre jamais
non ah vous allez vous laisser insulter
bah si vous m'insultez je ne frappe
haché dessus
avec les sentiments massif le taux de
chômage oui 38%, non 61% oui il y a 33
mais la question c'est pas la question
de savoir si la peine est clémente ou
pas c'est pas l'enjeu voyez enfin on est
il est pas venu en larmoyant en disant
ah j'ai passé des mois en prison c'est
trop injuste on est dans un système
dictatorial etc il est là pour expliquer
ce qu'il y a eu comme ressenti au
préalable et essayer de comprendre et de
faire comprendre à des gens qui sont
forcément pas forcément proches des
préoccupations qui aujourd'hui
traversent ces personnages dire voilà
pourquoi ça s'est passé ce qui s'est
passé il cherche pas mais vous êtes il y
a un truc un peu inquisitorial un peu
moyenâgeeux de dire présente tes excuses
dit pardon regrette sinon tu iras non
écoutez il a le droit d'assumer son
geste de dire
un peu c'est arrivé c'est comme ça
est-ce que ça aurait pu être mieux fait
moins fait ce qu'il aurait pu faire
autre chose un coup de poing voilà c'est
ça